[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
hallo zusammen hier ist Tatort
Deutschland mit Teil 2 des Rätsels um
die Familie Sutter ich bin Stefan
Netzeband und hier ist Mirko Kasimir am
Weihnachtsabend des Jahres 1945 für 100
kurz noch mal ab da wurde das Haus der
italienischen Familie Soda im
US-amerikanischen Städtchen verjährt in
Virginia von einem schrecklichen Feuer
verwüstet ist zusammengebrochen das Haus
die soll das hatten zehn Kinder eines
war zu diesem Zeitpunkt des Brandes in
Europa der
ältere Sohn der war Soldat geworden vier
Kindern gelang es dem Feuer zu entkommen
und auch die Eltern konnten sich retten
aber fünf Kinder verschwanden in dieser
Brandnacht ohne jede Spur um 1 Uhr
morgens wurde Mutter Jenny von einem
Knall auf dem Dach geweckt danach schl
sie wieder ein nach einer weiteren
halben Stunde wachte sie erneut auf und
bemerkte Rauch als sie aufstand stellte
sie fest dass der Raum den ihr Mann
George als sein Büro benutzte rund um
die Telefonleitung und den
Sicherungskasten in Flammen stand im
Folgenden konnten George und Jenny vier
Kinder und sich selbst aus dem Haus
retten der Weg ins Obergeschoss in dem
die fünf anderen Kinder schliefen war
aber wegen der Flammen versperrt in den
verkohlten Resten des Hauses wurden
keinerlei Spuren der vermissten Kinder
gefunden
wir befinden uns am Morgen nach dem
verheerenden Feuer Chief Morris der Mann
der in der Nacht noch meinte man müsste
sich nicht besonders beeilen scheint es
nun sehr eilig zu haben die Ermittlungen
abzuschließen schon gegen 10 Uhr an
diesem Morgen teilt er den soll das mit
dass ihre Kinder vollständig verbrannt
sein und deshalb keine Leichen gefunden
werden könnten
Stunden nachdem er und seine Männer
überhaupt da eingetroffen sind erklärt
er alles für beendet wirklich unfassbar
es soll noch weitere Untersuchungen
angestellt werden man plant vielleicht
noch weiter zu suchen vielleicht auch
mit der Unterstützung von Spezialisten
aber erst einmal ist Weihnachten und
Morris vertagt die ganze Sache na super
der Mann wird mir ja immer sympathischer
also ernsthaft Jenny und George sonder
glauben ihm erstmal und der Vater George
will alles tun um die Familie zu
beschützen vor der Trauer beschützen
vielleicht vor dem kompletten
Zusammenbruch man weiß es nicht so genau
am 29 Dezember auf jeden Fall der
planiert er tatsächlich zum Platz auf
dem das Haus seiner Familie gestanden
hatte die Familie erträgt den Anblick
der Trümmer nämlich keinen Tag länger
sie wollen die Stelle mit Erde bedecken
und mit Blumen bepflanzen ein Mahnmal
und Grab für fünf unschuldige Kinder am
20 dezember werden die Untersuchungen
wenn man es denn so nennen will
offiziell abgeschlossen als Brandursache
wird eine fehlerhafte Verkabelung der
Elektrik angegeben ein Unfall der Corona
ein untersuchungsbeamter stellt
Totenscheine für fünf Kinder aus deren
Leichen nicht mehr aufzufinden sind aber
ein paar Tage später beginnen dieser
dass sich Fragen zu stellen viele Fragen
wurde das Feuer wirklich durch eine
fehlerhafte Verkabelung ausgelöst sie
erinnern sich dass die
Weihnachtsbaumbeleuchtung noch brannte
als sie aus dem Haus flohen die Elektrik
hat also noch funktioniert sie finden
die Leiter die sonst immer an die
Hauswand gelehnt stand an einer Böschung
mehr als 20 Meter vom Haus entfernt wie
ist sie denn dahin gekommen ein
Telefontechniker teilt ihnen mit dass
das Telefonkabel nicht wie ursprünglich
angenommen durchgebrannt ist sondern
durchtrennt wurde
das muss zwischen dem mysteriösen Anruf
der fremden Frau und dem Brand passiert
sein und wie konnten in der Brandnacht
beide Lastwagen auf dem Grundstück
Versagen aber vor allem eine Frage
beschäftigt sie war es wirklich möglich
dass die Kinder so weit verbrannt sind
dass keine Spur mehr von ihnen zu finden
ist da kommt wirklich einiges an
zweifeln zusammen und das ist erst der
Anfang muss man sagen aber lass uns
zuerst mal über die Leichen reden
nachdem für die Feuerwehr der Fall klar
ist beginnen Jenny und George Sorger
selbst zu recherchieren und zu
experimentieren Sie versuchen Tier
Kadaver so weit zu verbrennen dass keine
Knochen übrig bleiben es gelingt ihnen
nicht der Betreiber eines Krematoriums
erzählt ihnen dass man einen
menschlichen Körper zwei Stunden bei
mehr als 1000 Grad verbrennen müsse um
ihn komplett einzuäschern das Haus hat
aber nicht einmal eine Dreiviertelstunde
gebrannt und so beginnen die das zu
hoffen dass ihre Kinder noch leben allzu
menschlich die Kinder müssen entführt
worden sein eine Zeugen meldet sich bei
der Polizei und sagt sie habe die Kinder
aus einem vorbeifahrenden Auto
herausschauen sehen während das Haus
brannte eine andere Frau auf einem
Rastplatz zwischen feiert will und
Charleston sagt sie habe ihn am nächsten
Morgen Frühstück serviert und auf dem
Parkplatz des Rastplatzes ein Auto mit
Florida Kennzeichen gesehen ein
Busfahrer will Menschen gesehen haben
die Feuerbälle auf das Dach der soll das
geworfen haben Feuerbälle okay jetzt
wird's ein bisschen seltsam ja ich weiß
das klingt komisch aber einige Wochen
später als der Schnee geschmolzen ist
findet Silvia in einem Gebüsch einen
kleinen dunkelgrünen Gegenstand
George erinnert sich an die Schilderung
seiner Frau die vor dem Brand einen
lauten Knall auf dem Dach gehört hat und
will in dem Gegenstand eine Handgranate
erkennen okay bevor wir uns das alles
genauer anschauen müssen wir vielleicht
erstmal darüber reden wer denn ein Motiv
gehabt haben könnte das Haus der soll
das anzuzünden oder womöglich dann sogar
noch die Kinder zu entführen das war ja
eine angesehene und beliebte Familie
eigentlich oder ja ja nicht bei allen es
gab in fade will eine ziemlich große
italienische stämmige Community und die
soll das Namen daran natürlich wegen
Anteil aber durch diese Community gegen
einen Riss
bis 1943 hatte Mussolini Italien regiert
und an der Seite Deutschlands in den
Zweiten Weltkrieg geführt und nicht
wenige Italiener in Übersee waren
glühende Anhänger des Dusche für soll
dahin Gegenstand fest mussolini war ein
Verbrecher und die Befreiung vom
Faschismus war das Beste was Italien
passieren konnte
es gibt einige Berichte darüber dass man
ihm das sehr übel nahm auch noch 1945
die andere Spur der
Versicherungsvertreter der
Versicherungsvertreter im Oktober 1945
will ein Versicherungskaufmann den soll
das eine Lebensversicherung für die
Kinder andrehen als George ihn abweist
warnt ihn der Mann dass sein Haus in
Rauch aufgehen und seine Kinder in den
Flammen sterben würden und fügten zu
wegen der schmutzigen Bemerkungen die
sie über Mussolini gemacht haben
aber es wird noch verrückt da dieser
Mann ist Mitglied der Jury die schon
kurz nach dem Brand entscheidet das ist
sich um einen Unfall gehandelt haben
soll und dann ist da auch noch die Mafia
in West Virginia ist sie im Baugewerbe
aktiv George muss als Unternehmer mit
ihr zu tun gehabt haben eine Theorie
besagt sie hätten George um Geld
erpresst
als der sich weigert zu zahlen hätten
sie das Haus angezündet und jemand der
in diesem Plan eingeweiht war hätte die
Kinder entführt um sie in Sicherheit zu
bringen das wird alles immer komischer
ehrlich gesagt ja ein bisschen so als
würde man irgendwas konstruieren um sich
an einen letzten Rest Hoffnung zu
klammern in der Tat eine Art Strohhalm
denn die Hoffnung werden sie nie
aufgeben dieser das sie wenden sich ans
FBI dass die Untersuchung neu auflegen
soll aber leider ohne Einladung der
lokalen Behörden können sie nur tätig
werden wenn der Fall mehrere
Bundesstaaten betrifft die lokalen
Behörden weigern sich aber das FBI
einzuladen als keine stichhaltigen
Beweise gefunden werden können dass die
Kinder entführt oder aus West virgine
herausgebracht wurden sind in die Hände
geworden die soll das Engagieren private
Detektive und mieten eine Plakat waren
da der Straße mit der sie jahrzehntelang
um Mithilfe und Hinweise bitten
immer wieder gibt es Leute die eins der
Kinder gesehen haben wollen und die soll
das Reisen kreuz und quer durch die
starken um den Hinweisen nachzugehen
doch alle erweisen sich als Sackgasse
1967 erhält Jenny einen an Sie
adressierten anonymen Brief abgestempelt
in centrality Kentucky darin findet sie
das Bild eines jungen Mannes von etwa 30
Jahren dessen Gesichtszüge denen ihres
Sohnes Luis stark innen wenn Luis
überlebt hätte wäre er jetzt in seinen
30ern auf der Rückseite des Fotos steht
eine kryptische Nachricht
Luis sada i love Brother Franky i little
boys und dann die Abfolge
a90132
seid ihr mal ein paar Sachen zu
sortieren oder definitiv Mirko fangen
wir bei den fehlenden Leichen an dazu
gibt es eine Menge zu sagen da ist eine
spätere Aussage des feuerwehrchefs er
behauptet man doch Überreste der Kinder
gefunden aber diese den Eltern aus
Rücksicht nicht gezeigt und sie wohl
auch verschwiegen das klingt für mich
total schräg aber okay vielleicht
wichtiger ist noch das eigentlich nie
wirklich nach den gleichen gesucht wurde
die Untersuchung am Weihnachtstag ist
bestenfalls oberflächlich und kurz
darauf planiert Georgia die Trümmer wie
wir schon erzählt haben als George 1949
eine erneute Untersuchung durchführen
lässt werden Fragmente menschlicher
Wirbel gefunden ein Pathologe erklärt
dass diese von einem mindestens
16-jährigen Jungen stammen Maurice das
älteste der vermissten Kinder war aber
zum Zeitpunkt des Brandes ja gerade mal
14 der abschließende Bericht kommt zu
dem Schluss dass die Wirbel
höchstwahrscheinlich aus der Erde
stammen die George für die bulldose
Arbeiten verwendet hat noch eine
Sackgasse aber es ist nicht
auszuschließen das Knochen Reste der
fünf Kinder bei einer genaueren
Untersuchung hätten gefunden werden kann
außerdem weisen ganz Sachverständige
darauf hin dass das große Feuer zwar nur
kurz brannte aber noch bei Eintreffen
der Feuerwehr Brand und Glutnester
existierten die eine große Hitze
entwickelten und die Leichen hätten
zerstören können das Rätsel um die
verschwundene Leiter und die
durchtrennte Telefonleitung kann schnell
gelöst werden man verhaftet einen Mann
der aus dem Schuppen der soll das einen
Flaschenzug gestohlen hat vorher hat er
die Leiter genutzt um wie er glaubte
eine Stromleitung an einem Mast zu
durchtrennen stattdessen hat er
versehentlich offenbar die
Telefonleitung erwischt wobei ich nicht
ganz verstehe wenn ich ehrlich bin warum
man die Stromleitung durchtrennen soll
wenn man einen Flaschenzug klauen will
aber vielleicht habe ich einfach zu
wenig Erfahrung im Diebstahl von solchen
Flaschenzügen der Mann auf jeden Fall
gibt diesen Diebstahl zu bestreitet aber
etwas mit dem Brand zu tun zu haben es
gibt keine Aufzeichnungen über seine
Identität auch skurril es gelingt
immerhin auch die Lachen der Anruferin
zu ermitteln die Jenny in der Brandt
macht das erste Mal aus dem Schlaf
gerissen hat und es stellt sich heraus
dass sie sich wirklich einfach nur
verwählt hat es gibt also für alle
Merkwürdigkeiten eine rationale
Erklärung
aber was ist mit den Lastwagen die nicht
anspringen wollten es war eine eiskalte
Nacht und George muss in Panik gewesen
sein wie leicht passiert es da dass man
einen Motor einfach abwürgt letztlich
bleibt es jedem selbst überlassen sich
eine Meinung zu bilden die Polizei hat
auf jeden Fall keine richtige Lösung
präsentieren können die meisten
Journalisten und Journalisten die sich
in letzter Zeit mit diesem Fall befasst
haben die kommen zu dem Schluss das ist
tatsächlich ein Unfall war und dass die
fünf Kinder in jener Nacht im Haus der
soll das Sterben ja aber es gibt ja
wirklich eine Menge Ungereimtheiten und
eine Menge Zufälle wie geht's dir denn
damit also ich glaube bei allem was was
wir beiden uns selbst angeeignet haben
dass das ist einer der vielen
historischen Fälle über die wir reden wo
die ganze Art zu ermitteln und auch
Spuren zu sichern und untersuchen zu
können das war alles noch so rudimentär
das haben quasi irgendwelche Leute die
bis vor kurzem noch so gewählte Sheriff
waren nebenberuflich gemacht dass dann
so viel verbliebt dass daraus nun
Mystery werden konnte insofern wenn du
mich fragst ich würde auch tippen dass
das ein Unfall war und man in diesem
ganzen Durcheinander und das Haus
abgerissen dass man einfach nicht
gründlich genug nach den Knochen gesucht
hat und das wahrscheinlich auch die
Dokumentation grundsätzlich der ganzen
Spuren und Beweise sicherlich noch nicht
so genau war wie das heute der Fall ist
und das im Laufe der Jahrzehnte diese
Geschichte diese tragische Geschichte so
ein gewisses Eigenleben entwickelt hat
ja und dazu kommt natürlich auch dass
die Säule das mit Sicherheit in so in
dieser in dieser tragischen Situation
gehofft haben dass ihre Kinder
vielleicht doch überlebt haben ja man
kann als ich natürlich dann wirklich an
jedem Strohhalm und versucht auch die
kleinste Möglichkeit noch zu nutzen
irgendwo noch einen Funken Hoffnung zu
finden das hat sich auf jeden Fall krass
geändert na heute ist ja eine ganze Teil
der Polizei aber wirklich alle alle
aller aller kleinsten Spuren zu finden
und anhand von DNA zurückverfolgen zu
können dass das macht ein riesen
Unterschied aber machen wir uns nichts
vor ich meine die verschwundenen Kinder
sind einfach wahrscheinlich auch die
bessere Geschichte und wir Menschen
lieben solche Geschichten wir wollen in
allem was passiert irgendwie einen Sinn
sehen dann kommt man natürlich mit so
einer Story einer Nazi Mafia Feuerwehr
Verschwörung irgendwie besser zurecht
als mit einem scheinbar völlig sinnlosen
tragischen und zufälligen Unglück ich
gebe Dir recht er hätte jetzt eigentlich
in den Theorien nur noch ein UFO gefehlt
aber ich würde sagen liebe Zuhörer Liebe
Zuhörerin wir geben das an dieser Stelle
auf tut uns leid auch wir können diesen
Fall nicht lösen es gibt nicht eben auf
alles eine Antwort für diese Geschichte
haben wir viele Artikel und Beiträge
gelesen besonders hilfreich waren the
children who Wendt ab ins smoke auf ist
mit Sony and mac.com
mystery of missing children House West
Virginia town auf npa.org und der
wirklich ausführliche Eintrag in der
englischsprachigen Wikipedia die
Schriftstellerin Stacy Horn hat sich
intensiv mit dem Fall befasst und auf
Ihre Webseite ist Daisy horn.com viele
der weit verbreiteten Mythen über den
Fall auseinandergenommen wir danken euch
auf jeden Fall fürs Zuhören bei dieser
Doppelfolge und wir freuen uns wenn ihr
bald wieder dabei seid euer Stefan und
euren Mirko